[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
gros jeux qui font l'actualité
le thème de ce soir c'est la généalogie
se plonger dans son histoire familiale
découvrir la vie d'ancêtres que l'on n'a
pas connu la généalogie passionne près 2
70% des français selon une étude du
cabinet opinionway un loisir à
l'enterrer rendu plus accessible grâce
aux nouvelles technologies
mais en quoi est ce important de savoir
d'où l'on vient pour développer ce sujet
trois invités romain du gaz chef de
service au public
aux archives d'or départementale des
yvelines michel renard membre du conseil
d'administration de l'association
patrimoine et familles à gan b et en
vidéo passe puisque les conditions
sanitaires ne nous permettent pas de
recevoir tout le monde sur notre plateau
vincent da polito trésorier adjoint de
l'association cgpi basée à villepreux
bonsoir à tous les trois alors chaque
semaine nous posons une question en lien
avec le thème du jour à l'eau
téléspectateurs cette semaine c'était
êtes vous intéressé par l'histoire de
votre famille et nos téléspectateurs ont
répondu par la finma l'affirmative part
dans la plus de 82%
romain du gard en tant que chef de
service aux archives départementales
est ce que vous voyez plus de monde plus
de demandes liées à cette généalogie
c'est vrai que la généalogie est quelque
chose qui passionne qui attire
je dirais qu'il ya deux niveaux on a des
gens qui sont intéressés par la géologie
à titre de loisir qui vont remonter
leurs arbres familiale et puis la
géologie on l'oublié parfois mais c'est
aussi un besoin administratif puisque
nous avons des géologistes
professionnels sont mandatés notamment
par des avocats dans le cadre des
avocats ou des notaires dans le cadre de
successions donc la géologie à des
intérêts multiples et c'est vrai qu'on
constate que même si traditionnellement
c'est une activité qui va intéresser
plutôt un public qui a le temps de s'y
adonner donc a plutôt un public
retraités il y a néanmoins une
participation de plus en plus vaste de
plus en plus large
un âge qui s'abaisse pour participer à
cette activité de loisir et je pense que
notamment la mise en ligne le fait qu'on
trouve de plus en plus de ressources
numériques contribué à cet engouement
est à cette démocratisation
je dirais de la recherche biologique
vous parlez de la moyenne d'âge fait
savoir qu'en 20 ans elle est passée de
70 à 48 ans mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cette volonté cette envie
de se plonger dans la généalogie
alors j'ai pas forcément tous les
facteurs d'explication sociologique à 7
à cette participation
néanmoins on peut imaginer que le fait
que surtout en région parisienne où nous
nous trouvons
du peu de gens qui sont natifs de paris
ou de la région parisienne et peut-être
une recherche de ses racines ya
peut-être un besoin de retrouver un
petit peu ce qui fait sens par rapport à
une histoire familiale
et puis je pense très sincèrement que
effectivement la facilité d'accès comme
je le disais de par les acteurs privés
aussi il faut le dire qui contribuent à
alimenter par à la fois des outils et
puis des ressources facilitant la
recherche contribuent à ce qu'il y ait
de plus en plus d'engouement autour de
cette activité
michel renard c'est un engouement que
vous ressentez dans votre association
est ce qu'on vient demander plus d aide
oui ça commence et puis c'est vrai qu'on
n'est ni à la disposition des gens pour
faire des recherches sur leurs sur leurs
ancêtres
surtout nous dans le cadre de notre
petit village on se rend compte que bon
on est tous plus ou moins cousin c'est
quelqu'un de séjour on pourra faire une
sorte de cousinade pas au sens où on
l'entend en temps ordinaire mais on a
quand même à peu près j'ai beaucoup
travaillé là dessus on est à peu près
vendée on est une quinzaine vingtaine à
descendre d'environ 280 familles dans le
secteur donc c'est vrai que ça c'est
très intéressant de faire ce genre de
recherche
et puis là on a aussi effectivement des
jeunes qui viennent on a fait la
connaissance il ya quelques jours d'une
jeune personne qui elle et elle est
assez jeune mais ça fait quand même vu
une vingtaine d'années qu'elle fait
qu'il cherche c'est pour sa généalogie
est ce qu'elle va nous apporter
c'est aussi beaucoup d'idées neuves par
exemple la part des deux défis ou de
challenge généalogique nous a donné
quelques exemples et c'est vrai que ça
va nous donner des idées pour pour
changer un petit peu notre notre vision
la généalogie l'ensemble polito je sais
plus quand des personnes viennent voir
des noms de vos associations quelles
sont les demandes principales est ce que
ces deux lettres pour les recherches est
ce que c'est de chercher à leur place
parce qu'on disait ça aussi un loisir un
passe-temps chronophage alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est plus un
loisir mais nous nous aidons en fait les
gens quand ils ont des situations de
blocage on leur donne des pistes on
participe aussi avec eux le rouleur on
les aide à chercher des points
particuliers des ascendants qui ne
qui ne savent pas où chercher voilà mon
nom du gars vous avez dit à plusieurs
reprises les nouvelles technologies
aident aux archives des yvelines il y à
de nombreux documents d'état civil mais
pas seulement qui sont lisses et plus de
5 millions de pages consultable sur le
site internet
c'est même plus que ça parce que nous
sommes passés à 7 millions voilà donc
c'est assez considérable effectivement
et voilà on a souvent la vision
effectivement de l'état civil qui est la
porte d'entrée classique dans la
géologie mais il faut vraiment insister
sur le fait qu'au delà d'un alignement
de noms dans un arbre
on peut vraiment étoffer la vie d'un
individu et de multiples documents le
permettent donc actuellement sur notre
site on trouve bien sûr l'état civil les
registres paroissiaux pour l'ancêtre de
l'état civil les recensements de
population les registres matricules qui
sont un peu je dirais le triptyque
classique d'accès aux données
généalogiques et puis des choses un peu
moins connu un peu plus compliqué
d'accès au si on peut entrer dans la
géologie par le biais aussi d'une
recherche sur l'histoire de sa maison
puisque le cadastre permet par exemple
de au travers l'histoire d'une propriété
de retrouver aussi les ancêtres et leur
possession il y à l'enregistrement aussi
qui a été mis récemment en ligne alors
l'enregistrement c'est un peu technique
c'est le fruit de bureau de
l'administration fiscale qui visait à
enregistrer comme son nom l'indiqué donc
à retranscrire dans un registre les
actes juridiques que ce soit sous seing
privé que ce soit des actes notariés et
grâce à ça c'est vrai qu'on retrouve
notamment les fiches décès qui sont
envoyées à l'administration fiscale et
ensuite dans le cadre d'une succession
les biens qu'ils ont pu être
enregistrées
donc il y avoit là il ya vraiment
plusieurs portes d'entrée et c'est vrai
que la mise en ligne de ces de ces
documents permet d'élargir le champ des
recherches
alors après c'est vrai qu'il ya besoin
parfois d'une médiation et c'est pour ça
que les cercles géologiques où les
sociétés d'entr'aide permettent aussi de
comprendre un peu et d'accéder à ce type
de document et puis de notre côté on va
essayer c'est vrai aussi sur des choses
un peu techniques comme le cadastre
de proposer très prochainement un tuto
tuto vidéo qui va expliquer un petit peu
ce que sont ces types de documents et
comment on peut y accéder
puisque c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
ça suppose de jongler avec de multiples
entrées de multiples tables et c'est
vrai que pour des gens habitués à
simplement taper un nom dans un moteur
de recherche c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça et jusqu'où est ce qu'on peut
remonter parce que les cris les traces
écrites administratif comme on les
connaît nous aujourd'hui c'est
finalement assez récent notre histoire
c'est assez récent mais si on prend
l'exemple de l'état civil est donc des
registres paroissiaux c'est vrai que
l'acte fondateur c'est l'ordonnancé de
villers-cotterêts de 15 139 de françois
1er qui impose la tenue sur des
registres d acte de baptême
alors pourquoi parce que certains
bénéfices ecclésiastiques nécessitait
d'être majeur et pour prouver la
majorité il fallait bien savoir à quel
moment vous étiez né sachant que la
majorité à l'époque surtout pour obtenir
des bénéfices étaient 25 ans donc c'est
vraiment ce qui a fondé un petit peu le
l'ancêtre de l'état civil après
plusieurs textes sont venus étoffer un
peu le arsenal juridique et notamment l'
ordonnance de 767 sur la réforme un peu
judiciaire entreprise par louis xiv qui
a permis justement l'établissement en
deux exemplaires de ces registres
paroissiaux un exemplaire à temps
conservées par le curé dans le cadre de
la paroisse le second est envoyé aux
grèves du bailliage et cette tradition a
perduré en fait puisque avec la
naissance de l'état civil donc en d1 707
en 1792
nous avons maintenu ce système même si
la tenue a été confié au maire et nous
procurer et le second d'exemplaires
était envoyé au greffe du tribunal de
grande instance celle exemplaire qui
arrive aux archives départementales
là on va on découvre un peu notre
histoire personnelle on découvre aussi
l'histoire de manière générale le dos
ben ça alors avant de vous tout d'abord
monsieur renard je voudrais juste voir
avec monsieur da polito qu'est ce que ça
apporte aussi de chercher de se lancer
dans qu'est ce qui vous même vous a
passionné dans cette dans la recherche
généalogique
alors personnellement c'est la recherche
de nos ancêtres de savoir ce qui faisait
oui vive et parce que ces deux régions
différentes souvent pourquoi on arrive
par exemple en région parisienne aussi
les voyages on s'aperçoit quand on fait
des recherches
les gens voyaient j'ai beaucoup aussi
donc au fil d'une rencontre d'un voyage
il y avait un mariage est une famille
qui qui prenaient vie voilà mesdames je
voyais avec les c est ce qu il faut être
passionné d'histoire pour se lancer dans
la généalogie
alors forcément il se trouve que oui
nous on est passionné d'histoire donc ce
que je voulais dire aussi sexy ça
rejoint la petite histoire rejoint la
grande histoire genre pourquoi par
exemple la gombe et il ya une famille
champagne j'ai découvert par hasard en
cherchant tout à fait autre chose dans
un petit patelin auprès de nogent-le-roi
qu'une partie de la famille avait émigré
en quelque sorte
alors parce qu'ils étaient protestants
dans karine parti qui a mesuré après la
révocation de l'édit de nantes et donc
et après j'ai retrouvé des traces de
tous ces gens là donc je faire quelque
chose là dessus mais c'est vrai que pour
bien des choses ça et on est des fois à
se dire bon bah tiens un tel il est né a
tellement donc pas c'était henri iv où
s'étaient joints 14 etc
vous allez aussi à la rencontre des gens
et ça permet de faire de nouvelles
rencontres six batteries prévue puisque
par exemple
dans le cas de notre association on va
voir des personnes âgées donc on les
fait parler puis à partir de là donc on
fait un petit peu leur généalogie de
tout et puis par l'intermédiaire de des
commandes de certains sites et s'est
trouvé plusieurs fois qu'on en voyant un
arbre par exemple ma femme un jour a dit
mais c'est mon arbre ça donc à lui pris
contact avec la personne et ceux devenus
des amis et ainsi de suite on fait
souvent de ce genre de rencontre ou bien
par exemple elle sonnait aussi dans
après avoir cherché fait des recherches
en lorraine côté paternel j'avais une
branche qui allaient dans les vosges et
au retour d'epinal je suis arrêté dans
un petit village et faisait voir dans le
cimetière il y avait des renards un peu
partout jeu il y avait une dame qui
était sur place à portal2 pas je lui dis
mais je le dessin d'un joseph renard il
ya encore 10 renard donc ici elle me dit
oui et mon mari s'appelle joseph renard
quand je lui ai dit que j'allais le
lendemain à la mairie de pour faire des
recherches à madiba vous allez avoir
encore une autre madame rona et ainsi de
suite c
on s'est souvent que l'on fait ce des
rencontres comme ça où même quand on va
aux à des cantons va c'est vraiment très
très riche et profond de la politique
j'imagine aussi parfois on trouve des
des histoires un peu drôle un peu
bizarre si on a des filles mères on ad
on n'a pas de père dénommé parfois des
petits délinquants aussi sur des
histoires des secrets de famille donc là
c'est aussi particulier donc est ce
qu'on a le droit de les dévoiler est ce
que est ce qu'on les garde pour nous
donc ça c'est un souci c'est vrai que en
fonction des histoires chaque chaque
famille a son histoire donc c'est
particulier c'est intéressant j'imagine
vous animer des ateliers aussi pour
aider on l'a vu il ya tellement de
sources différentes
on peut se perdre quand on fait une
généalogie complètement c'est quoi
au début on va on part de soi même mais
après ça peut vite devenir ingérable
parce que il ya plein de pistes donc au
départ c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
très carré nous au cg vie on propose on
se réunit une fois par mois on fait une
permanence et on propose des thèmes que
ce soit par exemple pour les archives
comment accéder aux archives
on a fait dernièrement retrouver
l'histoire de sa maison voilà on a aussi
fait l'année dernière les poilus elle
évolue justement cette semaine que vous
en parler parce que vos mains du gars
pour le centenaire du conflit vous aviez
fait appel aux volontaires vous fait
encore appel il reste des chiche a
recensé est ce que c'est un système
qu'un jour vous pourriez développer pour
tous vos fonds d'archivés pour avoir
finalement tous référencés alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux choses
l'index est ce qu'on appelle
l'indexation au fait c'est à dire
référencer les noms les patronymes dans
des documents en fin de vie accéder plus
facilement par une recherche nominatives
c'est quelque chose qui s'est fait dans
d'autres services des archives sur
l'état civil sur les recensements tous
les documents nomine tous les grands
font toutes les grandes séries
nominatives
notre opération elle va plus loin
puisque en fait l'indexation nous
l'avons mené avec un prestataire ce qui
a permis effectivement d'accéder
beaucoup plus facilement aux fiches
matricule recherché l'opération qui a
été proposée de façon collaborative
auprès des internautes visait à
documenter les fiches matricule part de
la notation donc on va au delà de
simplement du report du patronyme
l'idée c'était de référence et un peu
toutes les informations importantes qui
nous semble importante à l'intérieur du
document est ce que le poilu a été
blessé ce qu'il est et tué ce qu'il a
reçu une décoration ou est-ce qu'il
habitait et afin de d'avoir toute une
série de données exploitables en fait
derrière puisque actuellement par
exemple tout très concrètement si vous
voulez savoir combien de soldats combien
de jeunes gens étaient mobilisés sur une
commune et sur ce taux de mobilisation
combien sont revenus combien ont été
blessées vous ne pouvez pas le faire
grâce à cette annotation et à toutes les
données qui vont ressortir on pourra
justement exploiter l'information
croiser les données faire un travail
qualitatif de recherche sur les soldats
mobilisés pendant la grande guerre c'est
vraiment l'ambition de ce projet et
comme vous le disiez
ou comme nous l'avons dit tout à l'heure
je ne sais plus il reste cinq mille
fiche à noter donc là il ya une grande
opération en cours qui se terminera
jusqu'à fin novembre
laquelle tout tout internaute peut
contribuer voilà donc c'est ouvert à
tous et justement quand on se lance dans
des recherches que la généalogie
finalement commence on découvre une
personne dans deux familles ne va pas se
contenter des naissances on pas se
contenter des mariages ne pas se
contenter des décès qui sont les plus
faciles à gan b c'est une petite ville
aussi c'est 2500 habitants environnants
quand on voit traces on re découvre
l'histoire d'une ville aussi ma bat tout
à fait puisque je suis en train de
répertorier tous la faim de m en fiche
aussi en quelque sorte tout depuis le
début et je note tout ce qui peut être
point de vue métier tout ça le lez
hameau et tout j'ai découvert comme ça
il ya quelques jours car un mot qui
s'appelle à green au tri on ne savait
pas d'où venait le nom est en fait j'ai
d'explication parce que le curé à 7 en
1743 il a marqué nouvelle ne nouveau
amofa c'était le décès d'une femme et
cette femme était la veuve d'un certain
guérido donc j'avais le nom de guy
reynaud tri et on peut effectivement on
va pouvoir retracer beaucoup de choses
concernant le village
l'évolution dans chacun des des hameaux
au point de vue métier tout sa
population parce que les recensements
commence en 1831 36 et encore ensuite 31
il ya juste marquer il n'y a pas grand
chose et après on a plus de détails ça
va nous permettre de faire quelque chose
dans notre association pourra faire
peut-être un petit livre quelque chose
là dessus
certainement
et c'est pas ça et c'est vrai que c'est
pas seulement des défauts s'est pas
aligné simplement des noms des dates
mais on retrouve je vous dis au point de
vue des métiers et puis après quand on
si on a la possibilité d'avoir des actes
comme les inventaires après décès de ça
on a tout le détail de tout ce qu'ils
possédaient donc au point de vue des
outils au point de vue de leur cheptel
aussi on va voir une vache sous-poil
deux roues etc et on voit aussi tout ce
qui est laid les prénoms
par exemple on nous on a des aignan
parce que c'était sainte et à
saint-aignan le vocable de l'église
on a aussi on a des quelques fois les
remarques que font les curés en fin
d'année s'il ya eu des sécheresses des
famines
si le par exemple si le tonnerre est
tombé sur le clocher que ça a cassé à
moitié le clocher donc il ya plein de
choses comme ça qu'on peut qu'on peut
retrouver et ça c'est quand on est
plongé là dedans faut pas mettre le
doigt parce que tout le reste y passer
un mois ça fait 40 ans qu'on parle et on
parlait des nouvelles technologies panda
polito c'est ce qui simplifie les
recherches
outre l'accès en lice c'est lé site de
généalogie où on ne fait presque rentré
le nom de la personne et l'arbre se crée
tout seul en faisant des liens
est-ce que vous aussi vous formez vos
adhérents ou les gens qui viennent vous
voir à ses idées je les citerai pas
parce qu'on a beaucoup mais parfois en
payant 100 euros par an il suffit de
rentrer un nombre des fois et ça permet
de faire le lien tout de suite
effectivement ces sites sont aujourd'hui
il y en a peu qui sont importants mais
faut pas croire que quand on tape un non
on va avoir notre généalogie qui va
sortir tout de suite c'est pas moi c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a trouvé la fiche de
la personne il suffit de rentrer les
noms des liens et ça fait tout de suite
l'arbre tout seul on a pu les petits
papiers comme on pouvait avoir à une
époque où ont copié est-ce que ça rend
les choses plus faciles ça on les choses
plus faciles effectivement mais moi je
sais que personnellement je préfère un
prix mais parce que bon on peut le
prendre sous le coude et puis allez dans
la famille compléter effectivement
l'informatique rend beaucoup de
de facilité mais le papier quand même
mieux
sauf que bon sur ces sites là il y en a
je bosse en particulier il faut faire
très attention parce que on va vous
mettre tout un arbre et il ya des
erreurs il faut absolument vérifier
c'est impératif parce que et on le voit
bien
et alain qui leur fait une erreur il y
en a dix qui vont l'avoir repris et qui
apparaissent aussi sur le même sous le
même nom
alors c'est quand même très utile je
trouve dans les cas où on ne sait pas du
tout ce sont les gens si par exemple
c'est quelqu'un qui est venu s'installer
à granby alors qu'il était dans les fin
fond de l'auvergne lieu de la bretagne
c'est intéressant de retrouver cette
personne si son nom n'est pas très
courant parce que saint martin ou un dur
non ça ça va être très difficile mais
pour un prénom pour un non un petit peu
plus plus rares là on a des chances ça
vous met sur la piste et après on peut
aller rechercher directement dans les
registres correspondants dans les
archives départementales correspondant à
les rechercher voir effectivement si les
traces de cette personne j'envoyais
réagir aussi un petit peu avant c'est
oui après c'est sûr que c'est quelque
chose qui peut alors il ya deux choses
quand on parle des acteurs privés du
secteur c'est vrai qu'ils proposent
souvent une aide à la conception
d'arbres généalogiques deux d'entre
elles de partage et puis certains aussi
se sont fait une spécialité de
d'acquérir les les fichiers numérisés
par les services d'archivés
départementaux alors je ne m'exprimerai
pas d'avis là dessus simplement il
propose c'est vrai une plus value
puisque souvent enfin il indexe en fait
et permettre de rechercher très
facilement sachant que si une personne
ne veut pas payer et peut toujours aller
sur le site des archives départementales
concernées pour faire librement la
recherche donc toute nation il ya deux
possibilités
il ya une facilité pour quelqu'un qui
voudrait pas du tout son bts acse des
facilement à la ge energy bon après moi
je considère que rien ne vaut quand même
la démarche de soi même c'est une
enquête vidange vache à lait les ir
plaisir de recherche
on va enquêter déjà ça c'est auprès de
ces mots de la famille de proximité et
puis remonter la piste pour rechercher
son art nous ça fait partie du plaisir
je pense que tout est généalogiste
et puis c'est vrai que même si des fois
j'ai vu le cas au bout de 20 ans d'avoir
le plaisir de trouver quelque chose
parce que là on a cherché vraiment et
papa en cherchant sur sur un site
ben c'est vraiment un plaisir
extraordinaire et puis certaines
sérendipité je dirais dans la recherche
c'est à dire qu'on va chercher quelque
chose et trouver autre chose il va se
classer généralement ça va aboutir à des
recherches totalement imprévue et qui
font tout le sel de ce type d'activité
est souvent quand on parle de généalogie
un poncif une anecdote célèbre on dit
que 9 français sur 10 décembre de
charlemagne à vous trois en plateau pour
ce qu'ils ont fait cette recherche
généalogique est ce que vous avez réussi
à le prouver pour vous même est ce que
vous dessinez lorraine richard de m pire
il ya un moment effectivement tous les
we ben moi j'ai eu le cas fait pour
plusieurs personnes même de mon petit
village puis ma femme aussi par atterrir
dire même d'un pape
ça peut être été extraordinaire mais
par grégoire 10 il a été marié avant de
devenir pape
donc il a une descendance et on aboutit
comme ça et c'est vrai que je vais
retrouver moi comment paysans
relativement fortunés du côté d'abu dans
l'airé loire qui s'est marié avec une
fille noble une dandrieu et puis en
remontant à près voilà on arrive
effectivement alors là c'est aussi une
autre source
quand on aime l'histoire on se retrouve
avec par exemple je suis retombé sur
l'empereur d'allemagne en train de
chercher son nom henri 1er loiseleur et
après on va chercher on fait des
recherches là dessus on apprend qu'il
s'est appelé comme ça parce que le jour
où il était élu c'est parce qu'il était
à la chasse avec son aide à son faucon
sur le point il ya des tas de choses
comme ça qu'on apprend quand on rentre
encore une fois la grande histoire
rejoint la petite mais bon c'est pas au
départ je n'avais pas ça dans l'idée
aussi monsieur da polito vous avez 7 ce
même engouement que monsieur renard on
quand on cherche bien finalement ne
s'arrête plus on s'est plus arrêté c'est
addictif on leur dira c'est une fois
qu'on met le nez dedans moi ça fait 20
ans que j'en fais voilà et g j'ai emmené
ma femme justement elle y est elle est
dedans et ma fille qui a 20 ans bassier
mis depuis deux ans voilà j'emmène tout
le monde a de la famille c'est donc un
un loisir à faire enfin mis sur ce front
commun qu'on va se quitter
merci à tous les trois à d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
on n'hésitera pas bien sûr pas quand on
vit dans les yvelines pour nab est censé
être yvelinois à se rendre sur le site
des archives départementale des yvelines
il y a beaucoup de pépites à découvrir
vous pouvez revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]